hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil then the
executioner you'll see I heard some
thumping over there whose thumping whose
are this thing thumping trying to get me
to shut my fist into it because that's
just gross
alright so else do I need I could go
even faster I mean for some reason I
value being mobile better than like
having just more damage because when I'm
mobile
I can dodge a lot more and I can avoid a
lot of damage better than a straight up
defense it's like a skill-based thing
not that I'm very skilled based in
general but hey this time I'm gonna hang
it this real quick maybe it's just cuz I
played somewhat evil within I know how
the enemies react but frankly I like it
much the shaking won't stop I can't
remember dad's face I'm slowly
forgetting who I am there are all these
monsters around it's like I don't even
care if they get me anymore but I at
least want to see dad one more time your
name is blue ok crack dang why even
bother putting that in there it does beg
the question why bother with this rather
interesting way of doing this when it
could just you know not be that hello oh
you got the face oh you got the squiggly
screw face so bad you got like nothing
on me cuz I'm amazing in every way I can
hear you out
Hey Dude how about a little bit of this
No where'd you go hey dude oh where you
going little baby for little baby little
baby running away little baby running
away whoa little baby a runnin little
baby a row where you oh I'm fast I'm too
fast for you where'd you go goddamnit
where'd you go damn he's quick he's a
coward with zombies where'd he go there
you are you ain't gonna get away this
time
Oh nuts - you okay
I'm amazing in every way and you are not
works for me I am really fast by the way
I'm like super fast now and I love it
it's perfectly okay with me all right
all healed up and ready to rock who's
with me some was it a psychiatrist a
psychic an I get in this door please
thank you uh sorry I'm a little wide
whoa run away run away remember dreams
you had in the days of a child make you
insane see see see see I know everything
about you watch watch Oh laughs laughs I
know where you are I know what you are
watch I know I know
nightmare will come future I know you
know I know I know I know I know okay
all right well you don't seem to be
you're doing so good I question whether
you're actually a psychiatrist or not
something seems a little fishy here but
we'll go for it Oh psychiatric patient
okay watching from beyond writing their
little notes transmission received
look behind the brainstem and see the
past perfect present tense you thought
it and I heard it we grab the thoughts
new bones and muscle all the different
ones all the same thoughts pulsing like
brain radar bouncing is not the
Serpent's retains his form but it stays
in form and function we joined we are
the new being hideous and beautiful I
think he's taken my soul I probably
wasn't using it anyway
I am his disguise
amalgam alpha I don't know what that
means but I'm ready to smash it in the
face it wouldn't oh okay this one
actually might be a little tough I might
have some trouble with this one how am I
gonna be I didn't buy the rocket
launcher that's what I didn't do
can I pick up like oh hello dude alright
I have no idea how to fight you
oh that's how I fight you that makes it
a lot easier fling it oh why why buying
take some of that we're gonna play
tennis with cars how cool is that huh
Oh what you don't want to play what a
big oh you went down what the hell
happened to him okay nevermind this is a
little more than a little weird come on
come at me bro come at me bro bro I'm
only behind a car what are you gonna do
okay never mind
come on
bang did I get you Oh what about some
poop what a bunch of poopy come here are
you
I'm gonna run out of cars headed oh wait
you want to play screw you and your face
did that do anything for you oh you're
not you're oh you are done ha ha a
little chain sockson
ok rub them ok I better back off backing
off now back it off now switching back
what happens if I put a trap out I'm
gonna get someone I don't mean to get
whoops I put it all over the car
whoopsies
did that actually get you whoa oh ok
Simon Says run away huh come on be fair
be fair about it wow I am too strong for
my own good why can't I just swing him
already
alright never mind I guess I just can't
they got that parking brakes on it's
really really tough
Don stop playing hockey just fall over
and die home any minute any minute any
any bye are we go excuse you
time for you to die oh no oh I'm so sad
for you comedic genius that I am okay
where's my daughter
yay high Swank rapid damage I said that
all wrong highest rank highest rank rep
advantage Oh God
okay so that was all of them right how
many more could they possibly be I think
I beat them all down
search for your daughter oh no your
daughter better go get her okay
save and then I'm gonna finish this
apparently yes please that was the wrong
one I didn't mean to overwrite that one
and then get a final upgrade I guess for
some more damage I mean I could give the
RPG that could come in handy
you coming explody
hmm
or I could just go straight up normal to
I mean what are these life maximum yeah
it's only 20 I might as well defense man
I got just enough for another one of
these good enough for me I mean what
more can I possibly want
oh that barely upped my life gate at all
unless you didn't actually increase in
size because it's not about the size
about anyway moving on gonna save my
daughter
her next phase the anomalous readings of
the rubic entity have ceased
despite this your daughter's progress
towards stem nomination has not stopped
ruling out ruvik as possible cause it is
reasonable to believe that the only
other test subject within stem is this
cause ah okay the last remaining test
subject is you have you been in direct
contact with your daughter transmitting
files on your daughter but your location
within the manor-house basement cannot
be determined what do I gotta kill
myself what do I got to do how am I
gonna fight myself
was weird
okay c21
- okay he don't look so good
he looked like he might be a little bit
of dead oh no I'm gonna no Joe Joe's not
there JoJo's not there oh hello
he's watching we call heavy
well it seems bet we're whoa okey-dokey
then who's in here okay that's the
rocket launch dude looks like a soldier
type nothing over here okay a little bit
of column a this is that dude and then
the only one whoo what's what happened I
missed it
do it again what was it over here what'd
I miss something happened god damn it
okay where did the doctor go everyone's
gone everyone is guys this me is me
isn't it oh it is me oh it is me there
was probably like a secret revealed here
but I didn't see it I wasn't looking my
eyes my eyes I don't remember writing
all that but that's probably me okay
wait so was there like something over
here
No dang it I thought that was gonna be
some okay fine fine fine fine fine fine
fine fine fine fine fine fine fine fine
okay well this looks rather final this
is gonna be the final final fou probably
okay let's do this let's see how this
ends
I mean obviously my motivation isn't
very like held on to this something is
getting closer I can feel it I guess
this is it
sorry dad I know you tried nosy parent I
got him this achievement noisy parrot
thank you okay that's just the bonus
realm uh yeah I guess it's time to go
let's go more it come on what do we got
here wants to go brah is it me you want
a piece of me who do you think you are
me no one's me now
ouchies okay goodbye
there we go then I can't exactly be too
sane and then I'm cracking my own face
open but you never know you never know
lovely meat you have on these walls
oh are those blood veins on the walls
great my favorite yeah
something don't sound so good oh this is
pause scary
sorry daughter I don't mean to scare you
I hang on a second
getting my bearings don't mind all the
weird bugs flowing out of me okay
oh no that's not good at all
ah so I have to defeat my shadow form
it's totally like legend to Zelda
okay ah so I have to defeat the evil
within myself is what you're saying is
that what you're saying cuz I got a lot
of tricks up my sleeve there's nothing I
wouldn't do to save my daughter so
daughter are you going to come I'm going
to come find you
but not not birdie I'm gonna save you
I'm gonna save you that's what I'm gonna
do save you based upon recent evidence
this will be the final test a single
subject has been stealing the influence
of each subjects as they die it's
unclear if this is some aspect of their
physical form within stammer paternal
relationship with the girl that subject
the one you must defeat is you if you
are to return even part of your
daughter's memories and free her from
stem you must sever your own connection
sure done done then do it it no way I
wouldn't do that there's no way any
father wouldn't do that of course he
would sacrifice himself to save his
daughter not even a question yeah so
bring it on me where you at dark keeper
oh what a clever name me oh you think
you're so smart with all your names I
get it yes I know yes I get it I get it
I fling down the trap when he walks by
and then he'd go dead that's how I
defeated him before where are you at me
come on yeah you want to go bro you want
to go oh oh no I'm so scared Oh No Oh No
whatever will I do oh no no no oh no oh
hell oh oh oh no oh no oh dear oh oh
gosh Oh Oh whatever will happen
well that happened ah
wait was that it probably gotta do it
more than one time oh no my visions are
wobbly wobbly Oh No Oh
so scared so scared oh no gotta fight
myself who do dark version itself
oh no facing inner demons and all that
oh hey dude how's it gone oh you know
you're on the wrong side
oh you gotta you gotta be a sword I will
crush him once more I'll crush him
anymore I'll crush him as many times as
it needs to to save my Dutcher hey dude
hey dude guess what hey dude hi hey bro
how's it going come on over here I got
something to show you I gotta say it's
really cool look really cool like so
cool oh god you're gonna whoa hey dude
abalone ball you bibley boo you're such
a booty pop Oh BRR all right fine you
know I'm play like down flop play like
there you son of a [ __ ] how about a
little bit of trap cuz I like a little
bit of trap traps are cool
you want to come play you want to come
play bro you want to come play who's a
good bite come on
well I don't want to kiss you but I mean
try like calling a dog
oh I'm so sad
Howie I'm in pain a little bit but yeah
it's alright alright fine I can walk it
off
rub some dirt in it rub some dirt in it
you'll be fine
okay can't quite see shapes all right
what do we got here where am I gonna
meet him hey dude oh you don't look so
good well good to see you again I'm out
of traps Oh
oh that's that's it that's a Santa
that's a thing whoa
you missed me all right where is he at
I'm too quick for him I'm coming to get
you
where'd you Oh what oh it spawned right
on top of me how's that fear oh come on
that killed me really one hit ko it's
fun right on top of me
what a bunch of oh oh no way
I'm all the way back here really what
I'm all I'm all the way back here really
you son of a [ __ ] game that was totally
unfair that was so unfair what a what a
little prick what a little prick you're
going down this em [ __ ] you and your
cheap tricks son of a [ __ ] you think
you can pull that on me punch a
shenanigan [ __ ] what an assbag what
a giant bag of ass how about you go [ __ ]
yourself huh
get some Wampus ruin you you want to
wampie whoo huh loser Oh Frick yeah well
I'm gonna crush you so good oh no no no
oh no just fall over and die loser we
didn't fall over and die huh oh you're
so good at what you do fine
he wasn't he wasn't like lunging on the
first time before how about a little bit
of oh oh I'm going right past you oh no
well that didn't work out as well as I
was hoping
and get back whoa what the hell that's
some I'll beat you straight up you loser
maybe I won't well there we go okay
there we go got you throw you in there
and then crush you up good whoops I
didn't quite get you in there
hang on try it again come on one once
once more unto the breach eventually
I'll get this can I get there we go
finally a minute now any minute now
any minute there we go okay now I'm
gonna peel up crush it do it there we go
got it okay I'm gonna get him next time
yes I know I know we've been through
this I know I know okay where am I now
all right here we go where's this dude
at why can't I go
here we go done and done that was easy
okay so now I just got to dodge the
doobies and I'll be fine and not get
stupid killed
okay focus on dodging first whoa where
where where whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
not cool not cool not cool Oh oh crap no
no no no okay where are you at where you
at dude
okay we're yet whoa where whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa crap crap crap where is
he where is he where the frizzy whoa
what the flip where is he where's e come
on you ain't gonna give me
crap crap crap for that oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa come on sec whoa gee now
if I just run and find him and find him
find him find him find him find him
where is he where is he where is he he
was here I didn't see him he was pretty
obvious last time I missed him no no no
no there you are you son of a [ __ ]
yes whoa whoa whoa okay
oh okay alright I get it I get I get I
gotta you gonna come at me bro whoop
miss me
whoa ah [ __ ] whoa whoa yeah you're
crushed you're done you're done you're
done
yes yes finally okay good enough for me
good enough for me there I go
all right whoa man that was douchey so
that was the sound of the daughter
escaping which is good but the question
is why was the daughter in there in the
first place
okay little strange because those are
bear footprints and she was wearing
shoes
that's
No Marial successful release from stem
permission directives the father subject
has slain all test subjects except for
the girl thereby restoring your memory
the girl became the only living being in
sine stem and this allowed her to regain
consciousness and leave stem in the
rubic case the prevailing theory is that
he left stem by entering the body of
subject Withers
the results of this experiment are a
great step forward in understanding the
dynamics of stem moving forward we
recommend that the girl be placed under
our control so that the integrity of her
memory can be determined the father's
death within stem was confirmed the
corresponding brain death of the subject
has not occurred this concludes trial 8
2 3 4 7 - bx a full report will be
forthcoming ok so that's it
probably oh that was it ok I it was it
was a simple dlc it wasn't really simple
dlc probably just like something added
extra given that there weren't any
animated cutscenes and stuff but it was
still really cool it was a different you
know different point of view from
everything and we got to learn a little
bit more of the intricacies of how stem
works not much of the intricacies of the
main storyline but hey a little bit as
more than nothing so it was a fun little
jaunt
it took me a while to beat that last
boss the last mechanic of that was
pretty douchey I will admit but it was
ok like I wasn't all that bad he did
reset me and I had to try a couple times
but I liked this a lot and the story
while not having a lot of substance
I do enjoy stories of self-sacrifice I
think that's a really cool concept and a
lot of things and it's one of the things
that always you know makes my make my
feels machine hurt or go into overdrive
but so I think that was really cool so
let me know what you think in the
comments below thank you all so much for
watching this is the last of the evil
within DLC there is going to be no more
that they have said until there's
possibly a sequel made so who knows if
that's actually gonna happen we'll find
out in the next year or so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for sticking with me through all of the
evil within it was quite an adventure a
lot of confusion but a lot of fun at the
same time it redeemed itself a lot with
Kidman's story and it
not that bad in the main story and this
was just a fun adventure into whacking
people with a giant hammer so thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video
oh so there was a secret secret that I
didn't get oh okay I see how it is yeah
I got an a New Game+ oh boy the Thord oh
boy sebastien battle room cool oh cool
the final execution chamber has been
added to the patient ward of the manor
basement alright then so there's another
subject inside there that I haven't
beaten but I don't think I'm gonna play
that okay that's the real ending so hi
guys